We're only a few months away from the return
of our favorite fast-talking, regenerating
degenerate Deadpool, and we finally got our
first look at Josh Brolin's Cable — and
all his tactical pouches — in the first
real trailer.
Fortunately, there's plenty of other stuff
to dig into too.
Follow along if you're unafraid of spoilers
as we break down everything you missed in
the Deadpool 2 trailer.
Red eye
The trailer opens with our first look at Josh
Brolin's Cable, a.k.a. Nathan Summers.
The character has been a beloved mainstay
of X-Men comics since his first adult appearance
in 1990, and his glowing eye is as much a
calling card for him as it is for his optic
blast-shooting father.
Based on his ongoing narration about being
born in a war, we can surmise that the movie
will at least partially follow Summers' original
origin as the time-displaced son of Scott
Summers and Jean Grey's clone, raised in a
dystopian future.
More machine than man
In the comics, Cable is one of the most powerful
mutants in the multiverse, but his potential
is dampened by the techno-organic virus given
to him as a child by the evil mutant Apocalypse.
The virus was meant to kill him, but he was
saved by a talking ship and a one-way trip
to the future, where he learned to keep the
constantly spreading techno-organic virus
confined to his left arm and eye — albeit
at the expense of the full strength of his
telekinetic powers.
Whether Deadpool 2 will follow the convoluted
story is anyone's guess, but in recent iterations
Cable has used a tricked-out metal arm for
added combat effectiveness after being cured
of the original virus, so it could go either
way.
Hope
Although the trailer didn't give away any
main plot points, the appearance of a battered
teddy bear on Cable's hip has led to speculation
that one of the storylines Deadpool 2 may
be adapting is Cable's stewardship of Hope
Summers.
Unlike the rest of the Summers family, Hope
isn't actually related to Scott, even though
she bears a striking resemblance to Jean Grey.
Instead, she was the first mutant born in
a world that had the mutant genome removed
by the Scarlet Witch's chaos magic power.
Regardless, Hope Summers has been referenced
previously, when her name appeared in the
first teaser back in 2017.
Up to 11
"What's the most pain you've ever felt?"
We're not sure who Cable's asking, but odds
are good that his gun is about to cause more
pain than the most they've ever felt.
Cranking it to 11 is a great use of the immortal
gag from This Is Spinal Tap.
"Why don't make 10 louder and make 10 be the
top number and make that a little louder."
"These go to 11."
But even better, it's a pretty perfect encapsulation
of Cable as a character and a concept.
He's the most hardcore mutant in the world.
Of course his dials go past 10.
"Mutant freaks!
I'll show you how to stand up to…"
"Not today, friend."
Not a mustache
One of the best gags in the trailer is a snide
joke that makes fun of Warner Bros. digitally
erasing Henry Cavill's mustache for Justice
League.
"It's a metal arm!
It's not like we're trying to remove a mustache!"
Based on what we saw of the mustache-less
Cavill in Justice League, a metal arm really
might be easier to make.
That said, the best in-joke from the trailer
is still Deadpool mocking Josh Brolin's other
Marvel character, Thanos, and his quest for
the Infinity Stones.
"I got the stones to help you.
Noooo."
Domino
We also get our first look at Domino, played
by Zazie Beetz.
This is the first time Domino has made it
to the big screen, although like Cable, she's
been a fan favorite for years.
In the comics, she's a consistent member of
X-Force, the secret strike team of the X-family.
She's an expert at shooting and stabbing,
but her best quality on any team is her mutant
ability, which encourages good luck around
her and means things usually tend to just
work out.
We can expect Deadpool to make at least a
couple of jokes about her mutant power being
lazy writing, but he'd better hope she's on
his side.
Another detail that the movie may or may not
address is that she also had a brief fling
with another character appearing in Deadpool
2: Colossus.
Negasonic Teenage Warhead
One of the standout characters in the original
Deadpool was definitely Negasonic Teenage
Warhead.
"That's the coolest name ever!"
It looks like she's back for the sequel.
She's grown her hair out a bit, but looks
as punk and angsty as she was in the original,
so we should get some great interplay between
her and Wade Wilson.
New team
In a blink-and-you'll-miss-it moment, we see
Deadpool in a plane flanked by Domino, Terry
Crews, and two hard-to-see mutants.
It's possible that Crews could be playing
Bishop, the other time-traveling mutant on
the X-Men, but he's usually working against
Cable, and has rarely been on X-Force.
"Don't make me hurt you."
It's more likely that he's playing either
Hammer or G.W.
Bridge, both frequent Cable allies.
Easier to spot is what looks like Shatterstar
standing between Deadpool and Crews.
In the comics, he's a gladiator from a future
dystopia called Mojoworld.
In between Domino and Deadpool looks like
what could be Chamber, a mutant who drew the
short straw of mutant powers with a bio-energy
that constantly leaks from his lower face
and throat.
Side characters
It isn't just mutants that are coming back
for the sequel.
Blind Al, Vanessa, Weasel, and Dopinder are
all seen in the Deadpool 2 trailer, but we'll
have to see how much time they get onscreen
with such a packed cast.
As far as Wade's unpowered supporting cast
goes, one character is decidedly absent: Bob,
the agent of HYDRA who was slyly referenced
in the original.
"Bob?"
"Wade?"
We'll have to see if Disney's lawyers have
softened up enough to let Bob appear in Deadpool
2.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!